what up Theo what up Brennan huge fan in
the podcast appreciate what you guys do
yes very she ate it we will do any fact
both games are Java Theo he looks like a
high school lacrosse coach who [ __ ] all
the players use your equipment yeah no I
got a debate club for you guys I really
recently went to storage and dug out my
old gaming systems and I want to know
when you guys were kids were you on that
Super Nintendo were you on that Sega
Genesis are you getting those coins with
Mario were you that Sonic the Hedgehog
getting those rings yeah now you also
might recognize this little guy that's
the Rat King baby
gang bro to my turtle yeah let me know
what you guys think Gang Gang buzzbuzz
culture culture cultural culture you
guys get a little alright in a little
respect out there might be the last week
you're here but we're dude I thought it
was cool man
oh he's the male Lindsay Lohan over
there is wrong that stacey dash over
there she just hit somebody
did she really she's a bad [ __ ] really
I think I interviewed her one time oh
she is bad remember in clueless she
never did anything after that but still
she was that clueless die me dime she
was yeah Stacey - yeah I remember
clueless I think what else did he ask
what this man asked oh what's this guy
one for Nintendo or Sega Genesis Oh
Super Nintendo
I think Sega Genesis some weird kid
always had the Sega Genesis to me it was
like what is it it's kind of shaped
weird like yeah which is good and the
karcher is on top yeah that was all
Montana football for games those rules
are no Sega Joseph's don't remember they
had odd world if you remember that with
Abe the alien that walked around the
outside a crash bandicoot remember
but that was later though the crash came
out later I'm crap man he's your friend
though okay that's later that Crash
Bandicoot game so they originally hit
with the Sonic the Hedgehog yes then
they came with tails right NBA Jam
no NBA Jam Sega Genesis like that are
super nintendo what was it on merit yeah
I don't think you play NBA I thought
maybe NBA Jam stars on arcade and then
went to thing really yeah well then that
band that's the winner NBA Jam he's on
fire
there that yeah look it up bring that
[ __ ] up D remember how great that was
and I'm Eric R Malone and Stockton Gary
Payton and Shawn Kemp oh he get home
[Laughter]
what are you I was on both systems I
don't know came out hot with both but
and then remember the Spurs you could
have Tim Duncan and David Robinson yeah
yeah it was pretty Jordan was never in
it though huh
Shakalaka yeah from downtown I think you
could be you could get a cheat code me
being good ball for sure he's on fire
but back in the day they had double
dribble remember that game yeah you
could sure white guy was on the colors
and feet away and facing the other like
this yeah and then you could face that
way yeah dude I like contra that's
that's Super Nintendo - yeah contra was
good Cointreau is regular Nintendo as
well left right left right up down up
down a B a B select start Wow
and you do that even practicing on CT my
ass baby
it's a lot huh there's my game bro that
was my game was it yeah contra NBA Jam
what else a tecmo bowl just play techno
yeah come on bro yeah jeopardy family
dude and with you that's a good game and
if you want to go PC join your PC we got
Wolfenstein doom when you're seven
Plumas or anything you [ __ ] your pants
that thing was scary dude and then
Wolfenstein Nazi killing was it oh yeah
Wolfenstein bro I didn't kill Nazis I
didn't see it was so intense I was seven
dad yeah no wonder your mom's [ __ ]
wearing a bathing suit at a comedy show
trapping bro yeah dude here's what I'm
saying his super nes dude Sega Genesis
was for somebody that was strange I felt
like or just different maybe yeah yeah
yeah cuz suck kiss on Sonic was a bit of
a beast of a game now Sonic was a great
game what you never knew anybody that
had it it was always to me it was so
foreign brother always had it man I
don't know where he got him here we said
the new [ __ ] hey type in top Sega games
cuz we're missing one cuz they I know
Sega maybe that was Sega what was Street
Fighter Super Nintendo Streets of Rage
beast
altered beast I remember that game
Golden Axe
yeah it's o toejam & Earl bro that's you
and me know it is bring up toe jam Earl
I'm the big one you're the skinny one
toe jam and her never played toe jam and
earl that's you and me bro that's you
and me I do remember that that was a
game no was it that whatever TV show
wasn't it I don't know but it's a crazy
game riddance yeah maybe dude you and me
are toejam and earl toejam and earl did
i remember that girl go back to the
other list this is a throwback memory
lane here mmm Disney's Aladdin get on my
face
Sonic that's not saying the games got
real weak y'all had uh Oh what is that
one right there you came out hot oh [ __ ]
oh you shall be the revenge of shinobi
and there you go yeah I got a little
keep going to say Tetris on that get my
face man
ya see this [ __ ] gets weird Oh your
homework that's a game I said this [ __ ]
is horrible
Earthworm Jim was my favorite did
nothing he got molested that's what that
sounds like
you know earthworm jim huh and gave your
body nicknames you might be right
yeah because I didn't have a second we
would do it all the time
[Laughter]
earthworm jim was big what do we got so
I'm gonna go with Super Nintendo just
cuz of NBA Jam
you know what I'll go is take a dude is
because I hate it and I'm trying to be
different
56% went with Sega boom you little [ __ ]
oh sorry
got that text from you guys that can you
happy can you have your guy texting
about anger and my bad dude I should
have said that man no you know I'm a fan
of both dude you know you did get you
did call it right
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]